las palabras no son necesarias para
narrar la tragedia que se vive en
agricole la pesadilla vivida en las
últimas semanas está reflejando el
rostro de quienes logran alcanzar la
población de esa polilla el primer
puerto de llegada de quienes huyen de la
ciudad
es terrorífico solo terrorífico
y por eso todo esto es tan difícil
muchas de las personas que han llegado
hasta que llevan días sino semanas
viviendo en refugios antiaéreos y para
salir de mar y autor ha sido otra
tortura porque muchas veces no salen
directamente sino que han ido de
población en población esperando que se
abran esos corredores humanitarios para
poder llegar hasta aquí
anastasia unido con su hija y su marido
dice que mariupol es hoy una ciudad de
la que no queda rastro los que
permanecen allí sobreviven con los pocos
alimentos que les quedan
ni siquiera puedo poner las palabras
juntas todo está destruido completamente
los barrios de la ciudad están
totalmente por los suelos
el terror de lo que han vivido en el
último mes no termina llegar a un lugar
seguro la mayoría ha dejado parte de los
suyos atrás
después de muchos intentos este grupo de
50 vehículos ha conseguido permiso para
hacer la ruta de regreso
dmitri para camino a rescatar a sus
padres de quienes no tienen noticias de
más de 20 días creemos que hay muchas
familias atrapadas con niños y muchos
tienen problemas de estómago o que han
estado tomando el agua de las fuentes y
tienen infecciones cada uno de ellos
tiene un mapa que les muestra el acceso
a la ciudad pero una vez adentro deberán
enfrentarse al peligro por su cuenta
lugar hoy había otra realidad su casa en
militó forns ocupada por las fuerzas
rutas cuando tomaron el control de la
ciudad
les dijimos que era nuestra casa les
pedimos que se fueran pero ellos tomaron
todo lo que quisieron destruyeron
nuestras pertenencias rompieron las
cerraduras se comieron nuestra comida
nosotros tomamos algunas de nuestras
pertenencias y partimos
van camino al oeste en ucrania pero las
acompaña el dolor de lo que han dejado
atrás no saben si podrán regresar y si
lo hacen se preguntan en qué estado
encontrarán